speaking of virtue signaling some bands
now are changing their names it's not
just the statues coming down
it's the bands dixie chicks
remember dixie chicks they were somewhat
relevant 20 years ago
i think that was the last time too that
they were somewhat relevant well
they're back kind of they're not back
with any music in particular that
anyone's talking about they're back
changing their names the dixie chicks
have taken out dixie
because we've got to cancel the south so
the dixie chicks are just the chicks
which to me is still pretty offensive
the chicks
they're the only chicks they're erasing
the lived experience of all the other
chicks
they've just got to be chicks but if
they're chicks don't you think that's a
little sexist
are they going to be broads dames i
don't think so
you think chicks is just referring to
birds what about all the other birds
huh what about the eagles speaking of
which probably got to cancel the eagles
so the dixie chicks
they're out and lady antebellum a
musician that i've never heard of
has changed her name to lady a which is
taken by somebody else she didn't look
into that so that's a big issue
lady because you can't be antebellum
that's pre-war maybe she could be lady
reconstruction
which is what happened after the civil
war but if she's lady reconstruction
let's not forget reconstruction is what
led to many of the
horrors that followed from the civil war
jim crow segregation lynchings all that
kind of she can't be that
can she be a lady well what's a lady
who's who
the heck are you to define to me what a
lady is
a man can be a lady thank you very much
there's no end to that when you start
tearing down the statues
you are left with nothing when you start
tearing down the names
because one word is offensive ultimately
there's nothing you can say there's no
limiting principle